how many teachers are on code like loads
of teachers during the holidays it's
crazy it was it was a mad situation so
me and this guy were just talking a
reasoning that he's offering me a drink
we're getting to know each other do you
know what I mean so then
Matt's come to get the business the
girls backed off the jacket now and he's
just like yeah I want to [ __ ] my
girlfriend what yeah they film it no no
no no no am I a prick
but then yeah like they're just lead
into it you get me
erectile dysfunction oh okay so he's
just sitting he's just he's just I don't
know what he's trying to do in the
corner but nothing nothing's working so
yeah that that happened so you were
basically rent a dick
uh no they're not yeah
all right do we sorry I have a question
with that would that be with a healthy
relationship
that is Ultimate communication right
there
I I think he had good intentions
she didn't cheat she did it you know you
saw what I did she definitely cheated
he was consensual you know he wanted it
I got two little holes in your story
though you said you just danced with her
and then left when she said yeah you had
she had your number yes and she knew
where to send the Uber she knows my
friend
so she knows my boy obviously I cut the
story down but she knows my way and they
know they know each other's friends so
boom that's how she really she actually
went to an effort to hunt you down no we
had each other on these times Facebook
was still a thing so we still saw each
other on Facebook so they're still like
we I kind of knew she was their type
thing but to me she had a boyfriend
she's taken whatever so when she's
holding my boy now I said oh my boys
come to me said yo you know someone so
was interested in you I'm like yeah
left it there and then the text come
through and I was like okay now it's
time to get to business
I have a question
like what would you rate Michael pull
your mic closer what would you rate her
out of ten she was actually good food
you know
like give me your number though because
I need to know I'm I'm gonna say can we
use seven she was a solid 7.5 if you can
use it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what was
your boyfriend what was the boyfriend
yeah ah so he was an attractive guy do
you know he looked to look like my man
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a
rematch
she haunted me against though I was the
boyfriend prison
a subscription type yeah but you know
what like it was weird didn't it so like
when I sold it up that's when I was
thinking like right that was actually a
mad situation so I didn't really go back
there he did he still Hollows me to this
day
he tries to introduce me to new women
he's got another girlfriend honestly he
will send me nudes and be like my
girlfriend wants black Willy
how
do I feel about what like the fact that
like in this in essentially just you've
been reduced to a sexual I don't give a
[ __ ]
you're gonna give a guy 7.5 gallon and
have a cup what that's that's the idol
situation for most men like that's
privilege but that is the problem look
at what you've just said and you wonder
why relations are working the standard
is you someone can call you even if it's
just to help with their black dick
fantasy
black d fantasies and you're willing to
go there I wonder why it's not the man's
fault it's a women's fault it's the
women's no I don't I don't think so
because like women are in control of sex
better in control of relationships amen
so yeah so if if they're getting all
these These Hoes like it's their own
fault
there's a guy taking the photos and
calling him in
responsibility exactly yeah
honestly not not even the boyfriend
because like honestly who's the [ __ ]
that agreed to it it's true like that's
weird is too readily available like look
at what is happening well I just think
unless the birth control pillow goes
away I just don't think that's gonna
change I'm still working on abortion
laws at the moment
before up in arms abortion is illegal
it's legal in the UK it's legal in the
U.S it's not legal if you don't have two
doctors sign off on it it is illegal to
terminate a pregnancy okay but it's
still legal for the most like why do we
always look for exceptions it's not an
exception it's not it's free it's legal
it's free it doesn't sign you can't get
an abortion okay do most of them sign
it's like I forgot I looked at the
number of abortions
yeah it's more like and on top of that
even here in the UK 40 of women that
have had abortions I've had two or more
so is it really that restrictive is it
is it really that hard to get one it's
not to get one but I think they try to
say it's not legal but you're absolutely
why do you think it's 50 50 though
the responsibility of relationships and
how it's going is is 50 50s like you
said it's both men's and women's fault
because to some degree like men
I feel like there's no Honor on both
sides women aren't honoring themselves
in terms of their body and how sacred it
is to
um have sex with us because we're
receivers whatever energy that man has
you're taking on that's what I think
it's because the sex isn't that valuable
it's really awesome it's been devalued
and in terms of men there's not that
like in my dad's time if you were if you
were having sex with a woman you would
be expected to do The Honorable thing
and make her an honest woman yeah where
is this honest woman she doesn't want to
be honest she wants to be having hot
Ghost Armor with Megan wait wait wait
wait wait wait because throughout time
if you're gonna give a man Pom-Pom he's
gonna take it so you're only an honest
woman if that's the intention from the
beginning but the intention comes from
how you portray yourself but that's what
I'm saying women have not been so free
and open with offering themselves so
what would you say bring back shame and
women then it's not I'm not saying
shaming I'm saying bring back the
sacredness of sex I just don't think you
can unless you get rid of the birth
control pill because that's when you see
marriage yeah that's when you see
marriage rates plummet and so I just
think like she's got a point but you
could say make it sacred but it's not
unless you're a virgin yeah and
everyone's up in women are up in arms
about them possibly making abortions
illegal like so much women are angry
about that well and even with um I
always see girls
um try to like raise their standards and
their value like after they've slept
around right and but it's like you can't
really do that once you've slept around
your low value and it's like and then
you're asking like the next guy to pay
more when you gave it to the last 10 for
free
good point very good point but then
equally as well guys be sleeping around
too it's a small it's a small percentage
of men though and the thing is like do
are women really picking husbands no
they're not they're picking whoever's
gonna understand like I think
yeah
how old are you I'm 33. I got married at
25. yeah that's not normal like in the
UK like the average age of first
marriage is 31. yeah I was married young
as well I was telling her my story of
how I met my husband how I met my
husband and I'd got out of a long-term
relationship and I wasn't willing to
waste time anymore I went on the date
and I took some time to heal I know like
but I took some time out and then I got
on the dating scene but I was very
realistic of what I wanted I was told I
might not be able to have children
um had a lot of miscarriages and I
wanted to make that one of my priorities
I'd had my career are going to UNI
whatever and I wanted to meet a husband
get well meet someone get married have
kids that was what I had in my mind now
my husband probably thought I was a bit
of a bunny boiler a bit crazy you lot
will probably think I'm a bit crazy but
I went out there dating for the
intention to find that that you know
life goal and I'd go on dates with
people and I'd be like look you know I'm
not saying it has to be now but I'm
saying I'm setting my intentions on what
I want now I want to get married I want
to have kids now most men would probably
think and I've there was lots of men who
were like wow okay okay like this is
first second date whatever but I think
if you're not honest about what you want
and you're not like honest with yourself
you're not honest with the guy then
you're just wasting each other's time
like I think these days people are very
quick to kind of like jump into things
that are you know casual sex or whatever
and if that's what they're looking for
fair play I've got nothing against that
but if you want something more you need
to be like open and honest about that
because other lots of people go into and
I've seen a lot of my friends they say
you know they don't want a long-term
relationship but realistically they do
and that's what they want but they have
pride they have you know they don't want
to be seen as like crazy to put that out
there and and then guys are like you
know then they're getting pregnant like
six months down the line or whatever or
they're or they're you know ex expecting
the guy to be around and and they've not
made their intentions clear from the
beginning so I think it's so important
about you're just wasting each other's
time if you're not on the same page I
you know my hubby was like okay raw this
is a bit march on a second date but he
was like I actually respect the fact
that you're being honest with me and
it's refreshing and I said to them like
you know what there was a lot of dates I
went on and they were like no I'm not on
that page like they're like you're crazy
and I was like ah fair enough see you
later next yeah next isn't it but yeah
at least I got what I wanted and I met
someone who was on the same page as me
and you know and we've got three kids
now we're in a good relationship and
we're both happy
so I love that I think that's that's
really admirable and that is something
that makes a I think you set a precedent
at the start of your relationship and I
remember I went on some dates last year
um
through a couple I went to a couple
girls I met from Bumble and one of them
she said that she would choose the place
we'd go because I was driving to her
yeah and I got she got in my car
and she gave me a post coaching made up
because she hadn't made any plans and
rather than tell me she hadn't made any
plans she gave me a postcode she'd made
up oh man and so I was putting it into
the sat nav and this wasn't coming up
and I was like what this postcode
doesn't exist and then she just made up
some light and about two hours later she
tells me that she hadn't made plans
since she learned so and instantly I
just went
how am I ever going to trust this girl
if she's gonna lie about something so
basic the very first time I met her and
that was it there was no chance no
interest in the second day she was a
nice person she was attractive she was a
nice person but she lied to me from like
like she was a friendly person
around she ain't nice
but yeah if those if that's the
precedent you're setting at the start of
a relationship run yeah there's no way
that's going to be healthy whereas what
you're saying is you were basically like
honest from the beginning you were like
this is what I want but I think that
you're
what you wanted is something very rare
and the fact that you're willing to
State it is something very rare I think
what happens a lot with women at the
moment I know lots of women because I
used to hang around with a lot of sort
of activisty types lots of feminism and
stuff like that and now that we're all
those people I was hanging around with
are hitting their 30s they're all going
why did I spend my time doing that
actually what I want is a settled
relationship I want to have kids I want
to get married and they're going
feminism kind of lied to me about what I
wanted and so that I think that's more
common than what you've done which is
far more adamant and isn't it feminism
in my in its own right because you're
advocating for yourself and your best
self and your happiness self right your
happier self as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible